Look into a mirror and wave your hand, and
your reflection will wave back at you.
In everyday life it's easy to take the effect
of symmetry for granted.
But symmetry is vital to understanding and
predicting how our universe works.
This relationship between symmetry and the
mechanics of the universe
were something Emmy Noether proved in 1915
with her remarkable theorem,
linking maths and physics in one harmonious
statement:
"Wherever there is a symmetry of nature, there's
a corresponding conservation law."
So what exactly do we mean by symmetry in
physics?
Well it can be described as a transformation
that leaves a system fundamentally unchanged
after the transformation has been performed.
It's a change that makes no change.
Take for example spatial translation.
If we have a system and move it to a different
point in space,
that system would continue to work in the
same way,
provided all of the relevant conditions of
that system were moved along with it.
In other words, the laws of physics are not
affected by translation in space.
And similarly with time translation, the system
can be shifted at any point in time
and its physics would remain unchanged too.
Even the most fundamental laws of physics
are themselves symmetrical.
They remain the same wherever or whenever
you are in the universe.
The symmetry of time translation confirms
to us
that energy cannot be created or destroyed
as the total amount of energy in the universe
always remains the same,
no matter what point in time you are at.
Likewise, the symmetry of spatial translation
leads directly
to the conservation of momentum.
And this is the beauty of symmetry.
It gives definition to the world by revealing
nature's parameters.
If nature wasn't governed by symmetry, we'd
be living in a world of chaos
where nothing is predictable or repeatable.
But if the universe follows the principles
of symmetry,
why is there so much asymmetry in nature?
The state of a system might exhibit a hidden
symmetry because of some external factors
that affect it, but its underlying laws of
physics are still symmetrical.
So while the sun's gravitational field has
a spherical symmetry, a planet like Mercury
can follow an elliptical orbit that changes
shape due to gravitational perturbations from
neighbouring planets.
It also turns out that not all symmetries
are equal.
As physicists peered further into the infinitesimal
world of particle interaction,
they started discovering some puzzling violations
of symmetry
that would add to an increasingly rich and
complex set of rules
through which we view the universe.
We now understand these violations to be an
entirely different group of symmetries -
local symmetries, that affect certain interactions.
Unlike the symmetries that hold true at any
point in spacetime.
These local symmetries are the cornerstone
of the leading theory in modern physics
- the standard model,
which looks at the fundamental forces governing
the universe.
As we delve deeper and deeper into particle
physics,
we discover more and more symmetries.
Each one revealing new clues about the forces
behind nature's most fundamental interactions.
Eventually we may be able to find a theory
that unifies all of the fundamental forces.
Whether one exists or not, the search for
new symmetries continues to have a profound
role in explaining the structure of our universe.